[Music]
New York University is one of the most
liberal schools in America maybe the
world but even there at least one person
is continuing to refuse to conform and
it's made life hard for him ironically
he is a professor of global Liberal
Studies his name is Michel recktenwald
he's suing the school and several other
professors he accuses them of launching
a harassment campaign against him after
he condemned political correctness on
campus that professor Michel recktenwald
joins us now professor thanks for coming
on thanks for having me Tucker so tell
us what you did to earn the ire of your
colleagues well what I did is started an
anonymous Twitter account and I started
tweeting criticisms of PC culture social
justice ideology on campus which was
really coming home to roost at NYU with
the enforcement of a bias reporting
hotline safe spaces the no platforming
or shutting down of speakers like Ian
Ian Oppel Asst and so forth and so I
started tweeting and all hell broke
loose so what kinds of things did you
tweet did you threaten anyone with
violence or tried to prevent other
people from talking not at all I merely
made criticisms about what was happening
not just at NYU but all across the
country and as you know the the semester
and the year went on I was indicated by
what took place over the year 2016-17
with as the campus craziness escalated
and you know you had riots by the time
Berkeley happened and so on and so yeah
so yeah I mean I was just making
critiques of an institutional
ideological adoption and the mechanisms
to enforce it I mentioned no persons by
name no groups no races no idea
identities at all and I was immediately
within two days of an interview
appearing I was called into the dean's
office and I was told that the interview
had nothing to do with my Twitter
account or the publicity I was receiving
and yet immediately it went to that
topic and I was told that people were
concerned about my mental well-being so
because you disagreed with that because
like this thing I must be crazy yeah
because I disagreed with them and I was
put on paid leave it really strongly
encouraged to take a paid leave of
absence to upset myself from campus
immediately and then a committee calling
themselves the diversity equity and
inclusion group denounced me hoarse yes
they denounced me in a doublespeak
Orwellian condemnation in which they
said I was guilty of for the structure
of my thinking so basically I had the
wrong kinds of thoughts so the inclusion
committee excluded you they excluded me
that's why I call them the conformity
inequity and exclusion group there are
so many questions here but I can't
resist asking did any of your colleagues
secretly approach you and say you know
you're telling some truth here no either
they are true believers or they're cowed
and acquiescence by the others it's a
very very chilling effect that's going
on on campuses today
you can't voice disagreement with some
of these policies without being called a
racist sexist or Satan himself as I was
called so how how can you think clearly
if conformity is required
you can't think that's the problem it's
it's about curtailing different
perspectives and different avenues of
thought and this is antithetical to the
mission of the University and that's
exactly what I was complaining about
well if these people ever had power I
think I think a lot of people would die
actually those are those are
authoritarian impulses so what's your
response to them now my response now is
that I after I got back from the leave I
was assailed in a series of blistering
emails I was attacked roundly for
nothing I mean I never spoke to any of
these people by name or directly at all
and they started to attack me calling me
racist sexist misogynist Satan you know
short pants white boy fragile white male
while saying that I was a sexist I was
basically pelted with sexist and racist
epithets you know it
one thing to stand up and take a
position that a lot of people disagree
with but to take a position against
everyone you work around takes a special
kind of courage and I just admire that
and I I wanted to say that you and good
luck thank you professor thank you